hallo leute ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video sind wieder da ein sondern will
und wir haben sollte ein spiel
rausgesucht darwins gegen thies und zwar
dass für die falschen sie auf
hochgeladen und das spiel ist auch schon
sehr alt auf jeden fall geht es darum
dass zwei komische menschen die sich
irgendwie boxen und ich würde sagen wir
fangen einfach mal direkt an
hier befinden sich auf einer eisfläche
und müsse wer weiß ich dass du hast
fertig habt ihr müsst uns quasi
gegenseitig von dieser plattform
irgendwie runter boxen ich muss erstmal
überhaupt wissen und kinderrechten mit
dem rechten stick bock sich irgendwie
mit dem linken fuß kommt
[Applaus]
hier ganz groß braucht einen moment um
zu schauen wie ich schauen kannst 2000
jahre später macht jetzt eine steuerung
begriffen dass daran lag natürlich die
ganze zeit über den kopf dass historiker
gibt es nicht ich mache mich schon
wahnsinnig verstehst du wenn du immer
kommen willst du denn da macht es aber
warum ich auch warum die ganze zeit hier
vor
das war kein abseits
was sicher der beste spieler aller
zeiten leute wenn ihr wollt dass max und
ich das wirklich mal öfter hochladen las
man fällt leichter weil das macht spaß
und es gibt unzählig viele webseite wir
müssen jetzt erst mal gedrückt wir
können es vielleicht auch nur für dich
und deine eigenen charakter erstellen
der jetzt hätte ich noch unruhe
wir sagen einfach der verlierer von der
letzten runde kriegten backpfeife vom
anderen wir befinden uns jetzt in einer
hd man irgendwie ich will wissen ja noch
nicht so wenig wie man klettern oder was
zum überhaupt da oben hin oder ich
glaube nicht ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen wir sind dass man von der wurst
gerissen werden kann heute steckt
ok max warum schreibst du nein wenn ich
gewinne weil das denn maxi uns noch zwei
mal sterben sollte sich das ganze
gewinnen sollte dann darf ich mag es
eine backpfeife gegeben aber ich zeige
dir manchmal komme ich habe meinen job
neuen skill komme ich kann jetzt so
laufen so band gestoßen
ihr werdet wert verloren und bekommen
jetzt beide ein oder keiner bekommen
ja oh mein gott also ich dachte ich boxe
nicht eine ganze zeit oder völlig unser
stil
die f3 euro + + + 4 verloren die nächste
und also darf ich den ton bitte noch
einmal inzwischen sehen bis 16 das ist
jetzt gerade das entscheidende wette
meine damen und herren also wir dass sie
gewinnt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin diesmal recht vorsichtig weil
ich keine banken kassieren würde
diese verschickten mails thema was
machst du aufpassen wir aus stehen ich
habe gewonnen gleich eins aufs maul der
verlierer von dieser runde muss so viele
liegestütze machen wir kann das war ganz
groß probieren ob wir es doch das ist
ein stoff schock ich will nur schauen ob
ich dich du schöner besser erst gar
nicht auf was tust du irgendwie kann man
ja nicht runterfallen oder weiß nicht
versuchen zumindest die ganze zeit
irgendwie
[Musik]
deutschland verpasst du okay ich
verstehe auch gar nicht in dieses
schwerkraft hier ausgelegt ist die ganze
sind wie soll man sich unterkriegen
wie funktioniert das sie gar nicht wenn
paar sekunden später
[Applaus]
remseck in slate weil ich sachen
probieren
der bau ist es normal dass die kamera so
scheiße war oder noch die augen ich
versuche dich die ganze zeit zu nehmen
und ihnen die runter zu chips und war
wegen dieser blöden kamera
nein nein nein du also ja bis jetzt
keine ahnung aber seien mindestens
diesmal die zigaretten konnten sie gegen
weiß merkel nicht handelseinig leib 20
hinten ja damit ich einmal runter
gefallen und hat noch gewonnen also los
machst du viele liegestütze du kannst
[Musik]
das war es kannst du suchen und jetzt
nochmal danach noch mal abspielen
leute machen jetzt noch ein
entscheidendes match
der verlierer von dieser runde ist der
verlierer von dem ganzen video das heißt
erst mal den kopf los und ich mich wenn
jetzt die taktik an die ich vorhin
gelernt habe so ich denke ich hatte ein
schädel brauche nicht sicherung hast
mich nach dir eine backpfeife springob
gibt dann kopflos
selbst gesprungen
ich habe jetzt übelste taktik und spaß
ich muss erstmal dahin muss sich bis zum
boxen oder ok jetzt ich nehme dich ich
nehme dich leichter auf nein nein nein
nein finger weg ja das stimmt
ich finds halt so komisch irgendwie ja
ja ja ja nein ja ein
beide beide bitte drop nein also das ist
doch nicht wahr
wir haben ihm eine übelste matches und
dann ist es die ganz so einfach noch mal
kurz ausprobieren mit hoch heben lassen
nicht probieren erstmalig habe man muss
sie erstmal schlagen denn irgendwas
funktioniert ja ich glaube auch man muss
irgendwie waren ko schlagen
ok jetzt ein erzieher und jetzt den show
mit beiden händen das ist letztlich
runterkommen sich hierunter auch sonst
mal und wenn das wenn das ein punkt ist
okay okay ich hätte nicht ich rechne
nicht hammer ich kann mich da geht man
im data und wer die ganze zeit jetzt
wissen wir tatsächlich wie man sich
wirft nach der 20
ich habe aber eine idee wichtig jetzt
übels einheizen kann die kamera
ich bin so ein profi geworden weiter das
ist doch nicht wahr
der stoff als ob du es geschafft hast
kannst du dich die ganze boxen die so
kannst du mich die ganze karwoche und
spaßige das klar die geht aus neuen wir
gleich auch alles kann man heraus kommen
aber es geht auch okay also das sind
schon übel zu kämpfen und jetzt wo mit
ihr
nein nein nein nein ich es der erste
punkt geht an mich es war aber ein sehr
sehr krank ist mensch gerade ja es geht
los überhaupt nicht ihren caro
wahrscheinlich oder immer wenn ich
dieses leben willkommen zu anderen die
kapo wie denn wie hast du es geschafft
da rauszukommen gerade eben habe keine
ahnung immer wenn ich jetzt sagen die
gefalle ich würde sagen der sieg wäre
verdient gewesen wenn du das gerade
gemacht hat ist aber ich habe einfach
kämpfergeist ich bin der fc durch
ich bin immer direkt kannst du gar nicht
ist welcher hältst du dich eigentlich
einmal an der reling fest oder wie
machst du das ich halte an sagte stetig
daraus dass sich jetzt alle knöpfe mein
gott er wieder gerettet
nein du musst dich einfach ein bisschen
vergessen
das ist wirklich das hat nichts mehr mit
ich find's ganz geil wenn es neben
kaffee anzeige gebe mit
ich brauche sich einfach nur ein
stattlicher irgendwie kommt noch mit
nein
wie kommt das zwar sei das sagt dass er
echt dass das war bisher mit dem bringen
oft kommt es weil er wissen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da war sie von mir meine damen und
herren es euch gefallen hat das gern
mein like dabei sind sich 1000 like
werden max und ich direkt wenn die
geklagt werden noch ein video davon
aufnehmen und das ganze mega viel spaß
gemacht
jetzt können wir auf jeden fall
verstehen wieso das so viele andere
youtuber auf socken und jetzt will ich
einfach an der stelle noch sagen wenn
ihm ein kanal abonnieren möchtet könnt
ihr das hier tun wenn ihr darauf den
smiley drauf klickt findet ihr auch
meinen job eingeblendet und hier unten
befindet sich irgendein anderes video
könnt ihr euch jetzt anschauen wenn ihr
es wollt wenn ihr sehen wollt wenn ich
trotzdem an draufklicken weil dann
kriechen klicks gut für mein leben